we are talking about lead magnets and
getting people off of YouTube and into
your business you have a business and
your goal is to get people from social
media from your YouTube channel to then
go and buy your stuff right the goal
isn't just to have X number of
subscribers on YouTube the goal is to
actually grow the business so that's
what having an effective lead magnet
does we've gone crazy what we're doing
now is making a lead magnet for every
video that we put up so here is the most
recent example so again we're going to
go to rule four right halfway through
the the 10 or just a little bit before
half
people you're still after one okay then
I come on also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
again interrupting my own video pointing
down below go click on this link link is
in the description very big this arrow
is animated the whole time right as we
started it it was just a static arrow
and I told my editor no make it like
make it bouncing and moving for the
whole time so I'm talking for I don't
know 30 seconds talking about that doing
a pitch there's me a static picture
holding an example of a worksheet and
the worksheet is specifically designed
just for this video and then if we go
here
get free access to our vault the PDF
Summers for every YouTube video here and
then you can go click on the link to
find it
this is a lot more work
because it requires us to launch right
now we're doing two new worksheets every
day
so if I click on that it's going to take
me here
access our vault or PDF summaries for
every YouTube video
I chose what one looks like some of the
highlights Etc
um this is relatively new so we don't
have any testimonials or anything like
this worksheet changed my life or I you
know I love the worksheets I love the
summaries but that that should be added
in here uh you know some again
testimonials just for friends and
credibility who was this guy meet Evan
and then again you can put your name in
and and get it this is what they
actually look like so you can see this
video went live uh just went live today
this one went live yesterday yesterday
so we're doing two a day
these are all different PDFs so if I
click on this they're not that crazy
right if you click on this
you're going to see who is this person
you're going to see the the lessons
you're going to see our three big
takeaways from the video
and then like we give them a space to
write
that's it that's a PDF
right it doesn't have to be super
complicated or super crazy
you know even looking at Dan's
presentation is nine steps of being a
millionaire you get the slides it's
great
right so people then sign up they get
this they print it off they write their
lessons they some people just like
having this you just want a reminder of
what the 10 lessons were
and we got it here
you know for each one we do something
similar
basically the same same template
so it's easy for the team to create but
lessons and then pull three highlights
that we like out of it and save it as a
PDF we started on the top 10 Channel and
then we started at so that was the
September 27th and then we added the
main channel on October 4th and it just
kept adding two videos a day ultimately
this can be a lot more
right
um it's really on my team and the stress
level of making all these PDFs every day
so as we gotten the system down it's
become a lot easier so when somebody
signs up
they go to the landing page you know
they're going to get an email to say hey
thank you so much here's the link to get
them they're going to go here and they
get all of them
so if they sign up to get access to all
of them
right and then when they're on here we
also have some bonuses and these are
these are some extra lead magnets that
lead into training
so you can get any of these three these
is from my movement makers program
that's what I run on the other Thursdays
every two Thursdays we're here every two
Thursdays I'm in movement makers
um and we took some of our trainings
from that and we made them free if you
sign up for it and you'll get whether
you want to be a speaker coach author
influencer you get three free trainings
from inside my movement makers program
that you can unlock inside of here and
then you get the email and then with
their email again you can you should be
sending a welcome sequence to get to
know you who you are your history your
favorite videos
Etc and then you can also be sending
them value every week in terms of your
latest video to what we'll do is we'll
take our top videos for the week and
send that out to the list
and then you can also have your
promotion sequence of whatever it is
that you're trying to sell
this is our new plan
new PDF for every video specific to the
video and it's not that complicated
right I think a lot of people overthink
it Tyrell could make a video drive it in
his car talking about the 10 things that
you need to do to get your first
ten thousand dollars in coaching
and people would love that video as a
lead magnet right and all he has to do
is say hey and if if he's making a video
on his Channel about coaching like hey
if any of you're interested in starting
your own coaching practice I made a
video
explaining the 10 things that you need
to do to get your first ten thousand
dollars there's a link in the
description go check it out I'll see you
there
and that landing page doesn't have to be
super complicated either like this was
the landing page that got us six figures
in email addresses
it's it's Graphics there's no this isn't
even text it's just pictures
it's just pictures there's not that much
that even talks about it and then when I
click on it it just goes to this
it doesn't have to be crazy complicated
right now there are tools to make this
look a lot nicer than what I've done but
people get so caught up on it looking
fancy and nice where it's really just
the authenticity that will matter and
the and the functionality that works
like this is this looks a lot nicer
but it doesn't have to be this fancy
especially at the beginning
so the topic today how do you reach out
to other YouTubers or people in your
field to collaborate with and I'm just
going to shorten this down to
collaboration so judging the value
okay this is a little bit controversial
uh the value of collaborations because
when I was first getting started
everybody said collab collab collab
collab you got to do a lot of collabs
you got to do a lot of collabs collabs
are the secret answer right it was it
was the buzzword I guess at the time and
I set out to try to do a lot of
collaborations the biggest one that I
did
earlier on in my in my channel growth
was was this one here with Charisma and
command this is the biggest one that
I've done the channel that was that was
much bigger than mine right so now he's
got four and a half million subscribers
almost and he made this video on me
talking about
uh how to be a networker and I never
considered myself to be much of a
networker
but he called it the introvert's guide
to networking he called me a master
networker based off this event that um
we're both at for YouTubers and I
basically introduced a lot of people to
him uh my strategy for networking was
really just listen to what people need
and then try to introduce them to
somebody who can help them with that
much more than me going up to people and
say hey I'm Evan how are you
um I'm I I suck at that stuff but just
basically listen to what people need and
then help them and so with Charlie this
is Charlie who runs Christmas command
that's what I did I just helped him at
the event say hey well what are you
trying to find then he he told me
um and I introduced him to a couple
people who I knew uh and then all of a
sudden I'm a master networker and he's
making a video on me so this video
worked out pretty well it was super
um
humbling uh very complimentary and at
the end he even linked up my channel so
I I took a screenshot of this end card
because that's if you click on this you
go right to my channel and that's ideal
in a collaboration is that it's not just
a link in the description but that
they're actually linking you up on the
end card for them to go right to check
out your channel okay so I thought oh my
God my channel is going to blow up this
is amazing this giant YouTuber is
featuring me this is fantastic come on
let's go and then I looked at the data
like when is this video coming up he
told me he was making it it launches
let's go come on my Channel's about to
explode
and then here were the numbers
so this is the day that the video came
out
so these are my Subs these are my Subs
gains so
I was gaining for this month right from
the from the first to the 17th I was
gaining 1088 Subs a day
then when that video came out I got two
thousand twenty one hundred the next day
was 1200 and then the next day was back
basically back to my average
so over the course of you know that
video coming up those two days that it
came up and popped I I got I gained an
extra 1200 Subs over my average right an
extra 12 12 over my average and that's
that was pretty good I mean it's decent
it didn't blow up like I thought it
would blow up uh it's kind of the you
know the Heartbreak every now and then
when you think something's gonna do
super well and then it just doesn't get
you the results it really made me start
the question is this even
worth it is it even worth spending all
this time doing this collaboration
versus just making another video I'm
already getting a thousand you know 88
Subs a day should I just prioritize
making videos instead of trying to set
up collaborations and and after this is
what I ended up really focusing is my
strategy to grow my channel I doubled
down on content creation not
collaborations
I was a big shift I love collaborations
I still do a whole ton of them but I
think for the the ability to grow your
channel the consistent content is going
to be your number one place to actually
get the results so
uh I've done a ton of collaborations I'm
doing a lot more today this Thursday is
my public facing day uh so the things to
think about time travel coordination
expenses is it worth the extra effort
does it does it help sure but is it
worth all of that extra effort to try to
go off and do the collaboration now the
one with Charlie that I did on Christmas
command I was already in the the event
with him we were already there we're in
Palm Springs we're doing this this
YouTube event so I didn't have to do any
real extra work I was just trying to
help them out and a lot of
collaborations have happened at those
events now we don't obviously have those
events happening right now but at events
there's a lot of collaborations
happening at conferences where they pull
you aside to say hey can I do an
interview with you hey can we make this
happen
um and so those are always fun to do and
and can help your channel but if you're
gonna set up a separate thing just to do
it it may not be worth it uh is it is it
worth you to
on the back and forth on the
coordination on the travel and the
expenses all of that
if you're only looking at Subs game
there's other reasons to do it but if
you're only looking at Subs gained it
may not be worth it um again versus just
making videos my typical advice is just
go back to default making videos because
every video you make is another shot for
people to find you and it's usually
better for the long-term results of your
channel I would say if they're 10 times
bigger than you those are the
collaborations that go after if it's
somebody who's just your size or smaller
if all you care about is channel growth
if there's no other value you love them
it's fine it's Biz Dev there's another
strategic reason if all you care about
is channel growth I would be looking at
only doing collaborations with people
who are 10 times bigger than you a lot
of times the value just isn't there to
do most collaborations and this is so
against typical advice that people give
but uh this has been my experience in
doing tons and tons of tons of
collaborations
um that unless they're much bigger than
you it's not going to drive a ton of
traffic
okay so then why do it why why do
collaborations why if we don't care
about if it's if it's not going to help
us with Channel growth as much as just
making content why do it well the first
is networking right yesterday we're
talking to pre-show too Pablo was
talking about my my one-on-one with
Jamie Kern Lima you know she just
created her book believe it we did an IG
live together we're both we both have
our eyes closed here because uh we're
doing a prayer I asked him to do a
Prayer live for us and she had never
done a Prayer live on Instagram so we
did one together
um and we're going to turn this into a
YouTube video so you know Jamie I've
known for a year we met I met her at
Brendan's uh house in in Puerto Rico and
she's part of our beach gang and it's
just good it's good karma it's good
networking to support the people in your
community who are doing things she went
from being a waitress and having a
thousand dollars in a bank account to
selling her business for 1.2 billion
cash so even if it doesn't blow up the
channel it's still good for my business
it's still good for my relationship and
it's still just good karma to do and
it's fun I like doing it right much more
than this video is going to help blow up
my channel
okay brain building
I mean when I do an interview with Tony
Robbins uh that that could help the
channel obviously uh but it's a it's a
lot of work it's a lot of work lining up
big people it's a lot of work it's a lot
of work reaching out it's a lot of work
maintaining a relationship it's a lot of
work figuring out the times figuring the
technology it's a lot of work to make
this 21 minute interview happen but it's
great for the brand so there might be
people who you bring on who could really
help you with your your brand that get
you're connected to them even if it
doesn't help your channel grow that much
it just puts you into a different world
um so we had Matthew McConaughey on the
channel recently we're working on Deepak
Chopra coming up uh you know a bunch of
other people that will help the channel
grow but probably not as much as if I
just spent time making videos but having
them on the channel elevates the brand
of the business that much more
so brand building Biz Dev
this was a client of mine Stephen Kelly
he used to run Sage Sage is an
accounting software company uh one of
the the footsie top 100 companies by
market cap in in the UK and he was the
CEO multi-billion dollar company and we
would do a bi-monthly so every every two
weeks is that by monthly or is that
anyway every two weeks we did a show
together on YouTube where we would
answer questions from the audience we'd
have a topic and then we'd answer
questions from the audience so that
series didn't help my channel grow but
but it was a business opportunity right
I mean if you look at the views on those
videos they probably did worse than a
typical video but it was a business
opportunity and and I grew to really
love Stephen and his View and his
perspective so it was super fun to do
but again the value isn't just in the
growing the channel the value is in the
business relationship
um and then it's fun
I mean I think people discount just
having fun is a good thing I'm gonna do
a whole bunch of interviews today and
most of them will be on smaller channels
you know like this one I don't I don't
remember who this guy was
um or what his channel is but it's fun
like I just like I like being the first
person on people's channels a lot of
times I'm the first person ever
interviewed and then they use that
interview to go get other people to say
hey we had Evan on the channel do you
want to join as well
um so I just found it super fun to do
even if there's no immediate Roi
um one example there's a guy named Nick
who I was one of the first guys to reach
out to him he started an Instagram
account
called book thinkers
four years ago when I launched my book
year one word I said Nick love the work
you're doing love to send you a copy of
my my book it was a tiny Instagram
account at the time and
he later said I was the first guy first
author to reach out to him I was the
first author to say to recognize him and
say good work and can I send you a a
signed book
fast forward to now you know three four
years later I launched build the serve
and all of a sudden Nick has the largest
network of Instagram accounts for uh
non-fiction
authors right so he's he's profiling
non-fiction book non-fiction book
reviews and he's got the largest network
of Instagram accounts for it and when I
said hey I got Bill to serve do you want
to review it now I haven't really been
in touch with Nick for the past three
years in between that
but when I sent it to him I said yeah
I'm down thank you so much you helped
you helped kick-start my Instagram
career you were the first author to
support me and he he's been a massive
help in getting the word out for a bill
to serve
um I helped him watch a podcast I was
the first guest on his podcast and then
he had all these other people Grant
Cardone and Jim quick and all those guys
on as well now I didn't know that Nick
was going to be this guy and most people
flame out most people if you're their
first guest on their show most people
don't take it seriously and and stop and
quit and they only they only go five
episodes deep or some people never even
release the episode
but just sit on it it's like whatever
happened to that interview that we did
together like oh I don't know I gave up
uh but every now and then you get
somebody who pops and I think it's just
it's just fun if you I see it as fun to
see it as a community service I see it
as giving back to you know entrepreneurs
and YouTubers because when I was getting
started I really struggled uh and so
I don't care if it generates traffic or
interest for the channel or not it's not
a strategy it's more just it fills the
soul so probably half the interviews I'm
going to do today after this are not
strategic just somebody I like or
somebody's story who I like and I want
to I want to help them
um and eventually a lot of those come
back to pay off if you stick in the game
long enough a lot of those do come back
to help
I want to talk about end mid and
pre-roll placements or advertisements to
help spread more awareness for what
you're doing
so ending CTA this is something that I'm
experimenting with Brendan burchard
so Brendan and I partnered up on his uh
a bunch of things that one of them is
his growth day YouTube channel and the
goal is strictly get people to sign up
for growth day what is growth day growth
day is his new personal development
program app it's designed to every
ideally every day have somebody going
live people who you know like respect
training on personal development could
be branding could be Mel Robbins could
be David Bach Dave Hollis all these
people to have them train and then you
pay one monthly fee and then you sign up
what we're doing is doing clips of his
videos and this this is part of his
Morning Show but this is going to expand
having Clips as his videos
and then on the end card is Brendan
saying hey if you want to like today's
the day you want to learn you want to
grow you want to set for growth day go
click the link on this page
and this is blank right now because we
just started the channel I have to get
the 4 000 hours of watch time
to be able to qualify so we've got the
Thousand subscribers now we just need
the 4 000 hours watch time
um but this is going to be a link that
people can then click to go off and sign
up for growth day
it's less of a let's build the channel
up that's more of a long-term play let's
build the channel up let's get tons of
subscribers to learn about Grote and
more immediate at the end of every video
Let's promote growth day and get them to
click on the link right
we have found tremendous success I don't
know if I've talked about the side
inside of brand Linux yet but we found
tremendous success with on the end card
just having one big call to action
instead of having multiple so typically
if you go back on my channel you'll see
that we had four things on the end card
there was the a video that you pick
another video or playlist that you pick
uh subscribe button and a link to my
website
and we found that as an experiment we
just tried one
and on most of my videos if you go and
look at my my content now you'll see
there's one big call to action which is
to watch another video
so if you want more from XYZ go click
the video right there I'll see you there
you're gonna love it and then looking
and pointing to to go there the clicks
on that one video
are getting more clicks than the other
four elements combined
so now if you look at any of the
channels you'll see like these arrows
flying in and people that were doing
work you know Consulting helping with
recommending the same thing
um different styles of arrows but
basically all these arrows looking
pointing like go click on this thing
so it's worth a test I haven't done
enough and I don't know enough people
who are doing the ending ctas like this
to drive to an offer instead of another
video
but it's worth an experiment
to see hey this is an option for me
because in my end card in your end cards
you can link to another video provided
you're in the partnership program and if
you're not it's at least something you
know about that you can build towards
but it could make a big difference for
getting people to click over to your
site it says new big passion project
um turning it into an app or I think the
app is actually already out or it's
about to be out
um but yeah it's awesome to see so much
change in addition to the personal
development field so this is something
to play with I don't do it on my main
Channel but we're doing it for Brendan
on this growth day because the number
one goal is get people into growth day
um
Ashley this could be an experiment for
one of your videos right hey this is
from our tapping app you want to sign up
for it it's right there go click it
check it out and measure to see how many
clicks you're getting from it
so that's the ending CTA
what I usually do is the mid Shadow and
this is much easier to uh
Implement as well as not impact where
people go next because if you're doing
this one we're having a heavy focus on
getting people to go to somewhere else
besides YouTube
where if your goal is to grow the
channel and make it as big as possible
you want to increase watch time and so
you want to have a video at the end that
you're guiding people towards and it's
always much better to have you picking
the most relevant video and you calling
out that specific video to go check out
than just having best reviewer or or
most recent okay
I do this one a lot myself personally so
somewhere in the middle of every video
we have some kind of call to action so
this is one that I did for the book
so one of the advice that Brendan gave
me for the book is have different people
read the book he said one of his biggest
strategies to help him launch his book
was he had people like Larry King and
all these other people uh read a section
from the book and he turned that into
video content to help promote the book
so my first question was okay would you
be my first Brendan do you want to read
the book and he said yes and my heart
was beaten to asking for that and then I
used that and got other people so
a lot of my videos probably half of the
videos on my main channel will have a
mid shout out here of somebody reading
the book so this is an example of Jay
Shetty but you know we've got
uh Grant Cardone and and Kevin O'Leary
and Ed my Ladd and lots of people in in
personal development that you probably
know and recognize and then it's check
the link in the description to get your
copy
so we're interrupting our video in the
middle this one is at this is a 30
something minute video and this happens
at the 10 56 mark
so somewhere in the middle of the video
if you do this kind of shout out at the
beginning of a video you're going to
lose people because they don't know who
you are they're not ready for an offer
your retention is gonna gonna drop
if you do it at the end like this one
you're also going to lose a lot of
attention because they just feel that
it's a pitch
um what's the advantages you can
actually have them click right here
instead of having to click in the
description
when you do it in the middle
there's usually very little retention
drop
because you've gotten them to watch in
this case you know 11 minutes of a video
so they're they're interested they're
engaged
and they know that there's still another
you know 20 minutes left
so they want to stick around for what's
coming next
uh so Tom bilyu has changed his strategy
and does a good job of this now where
he'll have a super quick mention at the
beginning but he'll interrupt his own
interviews
at an appropriate point to talk about
whoever the sponsor is of the video
so somewhere in the middle of the video
in the most appropriate Place possible
normally for something like this you
know if we're doing 10 hard choices you
need to make in life we've probably
included a Jay Shetty compilation of
video somewhere here and then right
after you watch the J Shetty clip
there's Jay Shetty reading the book
right after you're watching Grant
Cardone interview like there's Grant
Cardone and I talking about the book
so this is to get people to
click the link it's in the description
we can't have it you know clickable here
as a big button like we can with other
ones
but we can have them to go click on the
link down below
uh Drew says is that mid shout out baked
into the video or you buy the ad slot
this is baked into the video this is
organic baked into the video you could
buy ad spots as well and we'll talk
about that the pre-roll is usually
better than the mid
um because we time it specifically
around something that I'm talking about
so Jay Shetty shows up after J Shetty
clip Grant Cardone shows up after Grant
Cardone clip the even the topic so Jay
Shetty would read this section he read
was about relationships
uh talking to Grant Cardone or somebody
else is going to be a slightly different
topic there's different parts in the
book The Brandon Richard one talked
about purpose the clip that he read from
my book so also trying to match it with
the theme of the video
so if you're thinking about you're
making a video you're gonna have a call
to action somewhere in the middle
while you're talking about your content
if you're going to make a 20 minute
video or 10 minute video
at what point somewhere in the middle
you know like in the one third the
two-thirds Mark does it make the most
relevant sense to talk about whatever
offer you've got
so you can customize it when you're
buying a mid-roll ad spot that makes it
a lot you it's a lot more difficult you
could do it it's a lot more manual to
like put a manual ad spot right here and
then to target that with your own ad
um and this is organic and free
so it's a constant driver people keep
watching this video
this kind of thing is better for a
consistent ongoing offer so
I'm still going to care about build to
serve in five years it's not just my
2021 marketing strategy and then I'm
moving on to something else because I
don't care about the book anymore like
it's it's a part of me I care about it
it's deeply important to me so I'm okay
with this living inside my video for the
next five years this is not good for I'm
launching this thing next week
go sign up
right because most of the views will not
happen inside the next week
series analytics this is where when you
have some kind of consistent content you
can start to look at what kinds of
videos are performing well versus not
so series examples could be you're going
to do a talking head video you're going
to do a coaching video you're going to
do a demonstration video you're going to
do a one-on-one with a client video
you're going to do a reaction video
you're going to do a how-to video you're
going to do a video from uh the stage
you're gonna do a big Zoom call video
like you're playing with different ideas
so that you can start to see which ones
are working out if you're up if you're
starting to work towards a Content
calendar and you're moving from the once
a week to three to seven don't do the
same kind of video on repeat
don't just stick to one format start to
play with different types different
content styles that that feel right for
you for example I don't do reaction
videos
um I find a lot of the reaction videos
are are kind of negative it's like I
can't believe he just said that oh my
God what an idiot like I don't like
putting that energy out so I don't I
don't I don't like reaction videos
there's no reaction videos the only
reaction video I've ever done is me
reacting to my first video and I watched
it back and was mostly embarrassed and
laughing at myself for how bad it was
um but for some of you maybe that's
maybe that is what would work super well
um so it's got to be it's got to feel
right it's got to be authentic but if
you're if you're getting to multiple
times a week make sure that you're
having different kinds of Series so you
can start
um seeing the data and seeing what's
working what's not
this is kind of a messy graph so I'm
going to explain it this is what I go
through with my team
every month
um and this is this is some old data but
I pulled it up just to show you as an
example
this we use for every series on the
channel so I just pulled three out for
you guys to look at this is a top 10
Series this is my top 50 Series and this
is the espresso which is a morning
Series so this is us doing you know top
10 and open Point free top 50 at Oprah
Winfrey espresso is more me talking so
be uh a clip and then I'm talking about
it and then this goes on so we have each
color is a different channel so these
are just two channels and then there's a
green Channel and then red and orange
and this is some giant sheet that I
didn't want to overwhelm you guys with
but what this basically looks at and and
um I've been on my team he he pulls this
together for me once a month and we have
a call once a month to go over it is
we're looking at watch time
for the past month of videos and then
how many subscribers we gain per video
so what these two numbers mean is
if we were making our data uh what month
is it now we're in May okay so for June
when we have our meeting this number is
going to reflect how well how many watch
hours did we get
per video on average in this series for
two months back so the videos that
launched in April
one month of data being collected
and then
we talked about it in June
the reason why we do it like that is uh
a channel that like mine has been around
for so long
a lot of the data a top 10 video from
2016 isn't relevant anymore to what's
happening right now
so I care about the new videos that are
coming up and how well they've done in
their first four to six weeks
so
the April videos
are contained so there might be let's
say there's 10 April videos in the top
10 Series so those 10 videos that
launched in April and if you guys have
questions pop it in the chat because
this this part might be a little
confusing so I'm happy to answer and go
deeper on it but if we release 10 top 10
videos in April
in June we then go back and look at all
the data
and say okay our top 10 videos got us on
average
389 000 watch hours and each video got
us on average 79 new subscribers between
launch date and June
between April and June now these will go
on to continue to do super well but
we're tracking what happened in the
first four to six weeks of each video
uh so what this helps us do is start to
analyze okay which series do we keep
going with and which series do we cut
so you know we uh we we did all these
top tens and I wanted to show this this
data is probably
2017 2016 data
um but we've kept this going you know if
I look to show you my recent ones should
show that the newer stuff
this is where we did our first top 50 to
say Hey what if we launch a new series
top 50.
let's just go super long on a video
so you can see our top tens we're doing
122 000 watch hours and 16 subscribers
per video in that month we did a top 50
and look at the jump it went from it
went to 600 000 watch hours and 61
subscribers per video
the next month did Super well the next
month didn't do so well we lost
subscribers and only 120 000 watch hours
so we're constantly comparing these
numbers and you can look at it across
Series so if we look at it this month
here
you can see okay so the top 10 got got
six figures watch time 17 subscribers
top 50 crushed it on both and the
espresso got 51 000 about half the watch
hours of this but double the subscribers
and so we're constantly playing with the
series to see which ones are doing well
then inside each one you can dive in to
see well which which video did well for
us inside here
you know so if these are 10 videos which
of them did Super well and which ones
didn't to give us more information but
this for you could be you know coaching
Series this could be again all the
different options direct the camera
reaction
Etc and you start to pay attention to
how many watch hours did I get from
these videos and how many subscribers
did I gain from these videos if you
wanted to add the third column of
Revenue you could too revenue is
typically more topic driven though
then series driven
um but if that's really really important
to you we don't track Revenue as a as
the main metric for our YouTube videos
um we care mostly about growth so
Drew's got his hand up what where what
do you got Drew so I'm just trying to
make sure I understand so each row
represents a single month
of that series having been released yes
yes yeah so this would be June July
August September you know October and so
on
so when collecting that data so I'm
assuming this is like on one
page and then on another page you have
each individual video the total
cumulative and then that number just
simply reflects the sum of all of the
videos that were released that month
yeah so if again if this was June it'd
be the sum of all the videos
from April that were released
and then divided by how many videos are
released so this is an average this is
per video oh oh okay okay yeah because
we'll do
you know we'll end up doing 22 top tens
in a month but only one top 50 as an
example
so to add them all up it doesn't make
sense you have to then give me on a per
video basis I don't think you have to go
this deep even just I I'm obsessed with
this stuff so I've shown this to other
big YouTubers like nobody tracks it as
detailed as you guys do
um so you don't have to go to this level
I'm just showing you the idea is I want
you to start thinking about on a series
level so we looked at Channel which is
great but that's
to Ashley's question about how do we
make strategic decisions that's hard
when you're just looking at total views
and total revenue
um total subscribers Etc once you get to
a series by series level it starts to
educate us to say hey these ones are
doing better than others so if I look at
this line and just a one-off month what
usually do it for at least three months
to see a one-off month isn't enough
typically so but this month like the top
50 looks like a a runaway winner and the
next month it's also looking doing
really well on the watch hours not as
well on the subscribers compared and
then next month whatever we did here
sucked right we lost 21 subscribers so I
don't know who we profiled or what that
video was now again all these videos
will still end up winning long term
this is first four to six weeks
and why four to six weeks is because
that's usually how long it takes for
suggested to start to kick in
you might have a crazy runaway winner
that suggests it starts to pop you know
within the first week but for the most
part for most videos
you give that four to six week window
usually after 30 day Mark you start to
see suggested views go up if the video
is going to do well if you still don't
see any suggested views after 30 or 60
days that video is probably dead
um so it could be worth doing a redo on
the thumbnail title or just the video
you know itself wasn't very good
so this is how every month every month
since 2015 uh I've met with my guy Ivan
and we go over this and we make
decisions afterwards from this and this
sheet this is only three columns this
sheet is maybe 20 columns long for all
of our series
and we'll just dive into each one and
say okay okay this one this one's not
looking so good what do we need to do to
fix it
and the goal is always to try to pull
out the always have one test series that
we're trying to beat
the rest of our content to make it back
in
so if you're if you're making three
videos a week as an example you have
your two that you know are consistent
winners and then you have your one
that's a test so maybe you're trying a
book review or maybe you're trying a
role player maybe you're trying uh a
coaching call you're trying something
for four weeks to just to see how well
are we doing and you're always trying to
beat the winner
so I'm going to talk about how can you
use retargeting and this is where a lot
of people
um mess up again when they're creating
their ad strategies so we we hopefully
know retargeting from our other
marketing efforts right somebody's hit
our landing page and then we hit them
with a Facebook ad or YouTube ad they
you know based off them their cookie of
being on our page now we can retarget
them as much as possible we can do that
in YouTube as well for people who have
viewed a video but have not subscribed
to the channel
so often one of the biggest ways to win
in the short term is you create an ad
group
of people who have viewed videos on your
channel and you can go up to 540 days of
data
they viewed a video but they have not
subscribed yet to the channel
if they've already subscribed we don't
want to show them yeah they're already
our subscriber right unless we just care
about views we want to try to convert
people
so the next set of settings when you're
creating a campaign we've got
demographics this one really depends on
how much you know your demographics if
you know that you sell to middle-aged
women great you put that in there if you
know that you sell the teenage men great
you put that in there otherwise leave it
open and let YouTube find the best fit
for you the household income one is
interesting for buyers so if you're
selling something that's really high
ticket
you want to be targeting the upper 50 of
people for household income uh that's
again only specific you're trying to
Target buyers because if you want just
audience growth we want to Target
everybody
and then here when you're going to
audiences this is where it can start to
get fun and we'll dive in a little bit
uh on this session so you can pick who
you're going to Target
and you can pick who you're going to
exclude
so this was this this is I just went to
my channel this is my one of my sub
channels this channel has 50 something
thousand subscribers on it so I tried to
pull something a little more close to
you guys
so not subscribed as 87 which is good
you want your not subscribed to be in
the 75 to 90 range if you're talking
only to your subscribe people we've
talked about this on previous sessions
and your Channel's not growing because
you're only talking to people who know
who you are so so this is this is a good
number you can check out your own
numbers to see how well you're doing but
we want to be in the 75 to 90 range
and YouTube ads currently past 28 days
makes up eight percent of my views
so suggest is number one this is where
we want to be playing always right most
of the things that we've talked about in
previous sessions have been about how do
we get more suggested views that's where
you're going to get the organic growth
uh but there is a little bit of an ad
Budget on this channel and it's driven
eight percent of the views
so I've done two different audiences so
when you're in AdWords you go to your
audience manager
and you can create different audience
lists and you know for the veterans here
you know what I'm talking about for
newbies just go to audience manager and
and go to audience list and then click
plus you sync your YouTube channels and
I'm marketing to both my main Channel as
well as my top 10 rules Channel viewers
and what it will do is create a list and
you can select how many days the default
is 30 days
I stretch it out to 540 so that's the
max
so anybody who's watched a video in the
past 540 days stays on this list
so even if you're not into ads yet or
you're on the fence or you're thinking
about it it's worth just setting up this
audience because it starts tracking from
the day you set it up
so if I set it up today it gives me 30
days back plus everything forward
so even if you don't plan on running ads
until next year
right if you're going to plan ads in one
year from today you'll at least have a
big audience of data where if you just
set up the audience in a year
you're starting from scratch
so at the very least you want to set up
viewers and subscribers for your Channel
the subscribers are helpful because you
can exclude them but also uh if you want
to Target them with pre-roll ads so if
you have a new book to sell new corks to
sell new whatever else to sell you can
Target them not only on your channel but
if they come and watch an Evan
Carmichael video they can see your
pre-roll ad before it pitching your
thing and they already know who you are
where most of the ads like hi let me
introduce myself I am this expert as
opposed to they already know who you are
they've already subscribed to your
channel those are going to be much more
effective at converting to a sale
so step one is just creating those
audience lists
for your views
okay
then we're in our YouTube ads campaign
we can see that I added these two
audiences and I exclude that people who
already subscribe to the channel
so it's going to go to the people who
have viewed my videos but are not yet
subscribed
to my channel
this is one of the cheapest most
effective ways to start getting paid
Subs because you're targeting people
who've already watched one of your
videos now maybe you don't have millions
and millions of views that's fine
you can set caps and limits on how often
the ad will show up
but now your ad is going to be showing
up no matter where they go on YouTube
right again if they're following me
subscribe to me or they're just watching
some sports or some politics or whatever
on YouTube your video will still be
showing up as a suggested video because
they've watched another one of your
videos in the past 540 days
is all this making sense am I losing
anybody any questions yeah I was shaking
heads okay
plow through but again if if you need to
pause they're like wait I didn't
understand that slide pop it in the chat
um but we'll also get the questions soon
we're targeting people who've watched
the video but are not yet subscribed and
showing them new content I like to put
in all the videos from the channel but
you can also pick select ones if you
want
so
this has shown what's happened in the
past 30 days I mean Canada so all these
are Canadian numbers so I spent not a
ton 700 bucks so let's call it 600 us
and I got 600 subscribers it's about a
dollar for a subscriber I'm targeting
the Big Four
I don't care about just getting people
from anywhere to I don't care about
their vanity numbers enough on this
channel to go after them I want people
who are in the Big Four markets that I
could potentially sell to uh so it's
costing me a dollar to get a subscriber
it's pretty good if I was if I didn't
care about where they came from that'd
be a lot a lot a lot cheaper right here
it's costing me six cents so let's call
it five cents to get a view US
that would be under a cent if I was
going International the half a cent
point seven five cents to get a view
from people who viewed already one of my
videos
so this is where we want to be paying
attention
earn subscribers
uh you can see earned views so I've
gotten 11 000 views that I paid for and
it got me 7 300 views on top of it
so I paid for these and I got these for
free
that's pretty good targeting that's
almost you know whatever you want to
call that's
65 percent of people who watch one who
watch the ad then go watch another video
on the channel
if you've seen numbers like that you've
done a good job with the targeting
and then 10 of them then roughly go on
to convert to become subscribers of the
channel
you can't optimize for this
so there's no rule that you can say
uh like sales this this is really
designed as a sales tool so it keeps
track of the click-through rate and the
cost per click and how many conversions
you get either just hitting your landing
page or hitting the hitting the
confirmation page you can tell Google
optimize for that you can't tell Google
optimize for earned subscribers
you just have to look at the report so
because it's an extra little step a lot
of people aren't doing it which creates
a lot of opportunity for you
Robert in the house for the ad video do
you always create a video as an ad or do
you promote existing videos from your
Channel
the existing videos from the channel if
our goal is to convert them to
subscribers right
I've I've looked at a bunch of campaigns
where people were making videos that say
Hey subscribe to my channel I'm going to
tell you how to do XYZ they make it an
ad
it just doesn't work as well as an
actual value
content
like think about what would you
subscribe to more
you know Casey hears from Jeff Jeff
Walker's team or Jeff comes on and
actually gives me
value teaches me something or Jeff comes
on and says subscribe to my channel it's
gonna be great I promise it's like
people just love the content a lot more
uh you could test it
but again you know my goal with all
these presentations to give you best
practices of what's actually working
right now so I would recommend you
actually doing
the videos on the channel either
specific videos and I'll share a screen
showing you what that looks like but
either specific videos that you want to
Target that audience or just all the
videos on your channel and let YouTube
decide which ones are having the best
impact
Drew says if you include the earned
views your effective cost per view is
actually three cents Canadian yeah
you're doing some some quick math uh
yeah almost
right I got almost
you know maybe maybe three and a half
cents Canadian you know two and a half
cents American right so this this is
just showing you how much people
actually are are connecting to the
content that you're putting up
so this is easy to get you know 11 000
views okay great
this are people then watching another
video on your channel that depends on
how not even how good the content is
because you guys have good content I'm
assuming the content's good when we've
talked a lot about your different
channels it's more about the audience
if you're targeting 13 year olds who
love Minecraft it doesn't matter how
good content you have
they're just not going to click and
they're not going to subscribe right if
they do is because they click the button
by accident so the target of the
audience becomes super important
so you can look at it on an ad group
level this is an ad group right just for
all of my top 10 videos and then you can
look at it on an individual video level
so what we'll do for this channel
because all of the content is pretty
much
the same it's similar
um we'll put all the videos in
and then we'll just sort by earned
subscribers and see which ones are doing
well now when it's under a hundred
subscribers gained it puts it in the
buckets
so
how many did this Bruce Lee one get us
in the past 30 days you know somewhere
between 61 to 80. as this gets over a
hundred it'll show you exact numbers
now we don't have a ton of data on
individual videos because
we max out you can have 300 videos in
one group
and we hit 300 and then we just slowly
the ones that get zero we pull out and
keep swapping new ones in so there's a
lot of data in here you can see this one
is AD number 110 ad number 104. we just
throw them all in and then let YouTube
decide to show the ones that are having
the biggest uptick
the reason why is because if if I was
picking
I wouldn't have picked any of these four
videos
you know I was thinking okay what are
the ones I'm gonna pop off the hardest
for me on my top 10 Channel I would have
put I would have put Tony Robbins you
know I would have put Warren Buffett I
would have put Oprah Winfrey I would
have put some of the bigger names but
it's Bruce Lee the Dalai Lama
Jay-Z Michael Jordan I wouldn't have
picked these four and yet they're the
ones that are working the best
so you you could pick if you know the
targeting super well but otherwise if
it's if it's General to the category I
just throw all of them in
because they've already watched a video
on your channel now we're letting them
letting YouTube sort by whichever ones
are getting the the best results
YouTube's not going by earned
subscribers they're just basically
trying to optimize how many views you
can get for the budget so we're just
assuming that the more people view a
video the more likely they're going to
subscribe it's not
100 accurate right like this one
um
61 let's call this 70 subscribers for
for 900 views and this one got 400 views
for 10 subscribers so this one's
performing better in the past 30 days
right
um you could if you really want to go
video by video by video we just throw
them all in my system does it and once
we hit 300 usually once a week she'll
swap out the worst seven and then pop
seven new ones in if you want to see
this full video as well as trained live
with me twice a month to blow up your
brand join the brand Linux training
program there's a link to join right
there next to me continue to believe
I'll see you there